[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
let's go yeah let's go let's go Chin
Chin showed up at my party in a with a
beautiful Mongolian woman oh Mongolian
oh dude from Mongolia so another shrimp
on the barbie bro putting I don't know
if they make sense doesn't make sense
but I like that you said it I know I
don't put another shrimp on the barbie
looks a little hung over did you have
some Junior I didn't see that he was
just having a good time
you got to watch chin is that right
undercover that the jelly roll was a
liability I did get drunk there so
you're gonna like this story so my boy
Ryan
one of my favorite guys
and uh you know his last name malciano
there you go and I always say it wrong
because it's out there malciano yeah
that's true so so he so he shows up well
he shows up with um
my girl wanted to do a green bar because
there was three pounds of
parsed out perfect
weed we're gonna block out his last name
but perfectly legal perfect yes it's got
a dispensary the best weed I've ever
seen 90 years in these perfect packages
but you're gonna like this he brought it
like individually yeah now he also shows
up with two cases of whiskey now I don't
know whiskey you know whiskey well hold
please hold all I know is my my
brother-in-law
Danny's brother is in a whiskey Club oh
that's how much he likes whiskey he can
collects whiskey he's a maniac and he
was able to look at the tops of the
whiskey when they were still on the
thing and no one ever with everyone and
he starts to freak out
so we start pulling out the Papi 23
Happy 12.
Baba what Baba he bring he brings out
the batch uh Four Roses he brings out
[ __ ] oh it's all different stuff crazy
[ __ ] but before like pre-opened pappies
or bottle original bottles Jesus Christ
so my so Michael can you invite him more
Michael goes
your boy and he starts showing me what
they cost in the internet if you want to
buy him he goes your boy dropped off
more than 40
000 worth of liquor oh easily and I went
to the Pappy's alone what
and then he goes and then the weed he
goes that's a hell of a drop off you
might want to thank your boy I was like
Ryan he goes I just love this I love
giving he's such a great guy well he's
in the hospitality business yeah exactly
but I was like resources because the
restaurant business the outcall business
yes all that stuff for me I'm like hey
do we want to drink this or do we want
to sell it you know but we put a [ __ ]
dent in it you better have that Pat did
you try Pappy's on your uh wedding
celebration I did Sir and you know what
now just so people get declared this was
in Brian's wedding Brian got elope I
didn't miss Brian's wedding this was a
party first a party celebrated and he
also decided to throw it on a Saturday
when he told me he did that I went dude
your closest friends are all kinds I got
a little sad we're all comics and we're
all we're all everyone's working
Saturdays so your closest ones aren't
going to be there I got a little sad
because at the end of the night it was a
beautiful night I saw all so many of the
people I love I brought the families
together but I didn't have my boy there
and then you sent me that picture from
us from 2015. 215 New York oh it was
great Tyler was that a Gramercy theater
yeah man old school how about that and
then I'd even say in the rest of
pictures I don't want you to cry on your
wedding celebration and then there's
pictures in the green room with you and
me Justin uh Jimmy Burke back there wow
yeah Jimmy couldn't make it because his
niece was getting married oh yeah you
couldn't make it Dove couldn't make
Kalia couldn't make it yeah Sasso forgot
about it it wasn't his fault I know he
forgot well that hurt my feelings but it
was yeah I wish I was there and I love
the the boy from uh Magic behind you did
at his house yeah well that so so yeah
so James James of magic mind
gave me he and his wife just get gave us
the [ __ ] house he goes do it at my
house I go I know but your house no I
mean it's a big party 80 people he goes
do it at my house I go yeah he goes yeah
just go ahead and that's what is it
Malibu it was beautiful is it Malibu it
was in Malibu and it was uh you guys
start out what time what time you show
up Jen I gotta when it started like a
three-ish did you meet James three yeah
talk to him I met everyone I call them
points well James not afraid to cut up
the rug starts dancing not a good dancer
and knows it oh no that knows it well I
got a video of that yeah please show
stuff we gotta show you that send chin
the video so fans can see it here's my
thing about bad dancers that are white
like that yeah if you're gonna do it you
just gotta you gotta You Gotta Buy into
it and you know you're a bad dancer and
you've got to buy into it you can't be
self-conscious no you guys gotta go for
it come in be like Jeffrey Dahmer in the
new series dance with the gay guys
trying to attract them that's right he
he was the awful dancer but they it
would get their attention
you need their livers that's right
that's oh there it is hold on hold on
hold on hold on also turn it down though
right yeah
all right let me ask you this did you um
at the party you were wearing a nice
suit I was wearing it I bought a suit
from Hugo Boss but but the the Couture
collection you got it tailored I got it
and did you wear sandals I did not thank
God
my buddy Brian Cooley did they've earned
that they've earned you haven't earned
it Daddy hasn't earned it so you when
you do about five tours and you can wear
sandals you think my girl would that's
correct by the way five tours and his
thumb could walk in with Crocs I
wouldn't say anything anybody else
walked in the garage door what are you
doing well Andy Andy who who who will
also break the world record in the
squirrel suit after he's been a Seal
Team Six guy and Tark and him fell in
love they were just like oh that's first
so here's James Bashar now hold on now
James who just gave me his wife just
gave me his house all right and then he
does not give a now hold on let me
humble James real quick because he has
all the money in the world and he's so
nice and handsome and giant wiener I saw
through his uh jeans oh really yeah I
was like oh wow
your grass terrible right what's that
the grass terrible the grass let's go
and water that grass gotta Water
California Malibu strict watering rules
let's go ahead and his dad who
appreciates good grass yeah I'm
disappointed well okay you didn't get it
you guys let's pour some of that magic
mine on the ground you gotta pour some
magic on the ground all right let me see
this guy I got I got some magic mine in
you too we just did our yeah of the 4.0
the news we're not sponsored by this by
the way every time we talk about this
just so you know we're not making any
money off this so just so you know we
just like it okay go hit it alrighty
look at him look look watch oh oh
look at that and he's not drunk he's not
drunk he's not drunk no look at this
look at this look at this there's my
friend Kristen Steinberg oh there's
Danny with feathers
and now this is the opening look at him
getting low
yeah
look at him
yeah it's that good so there it is a
good time Rich frat boy Vibe that's that
good job and I hate I missed it
well it's got San Antonio it got it was
Tark it was Ryan it was like yeah oh my
God come on bro because I saw Joseph at
the game
Joseph is he might be
t-h-e-best I [ __ ] love that guy the
best yep I love that [ __ ] I
loved and I love Joseph because he's one
of those friends he's busy I'm busy we
don't see each other when we do it's
just like oh you know those friends you
have to worry about they love you what
have you been doing what are you up to
like we don't talk about bit nothing no
dude it's about a laugh it's about a
laugh
it was great man yeah I hate I missed it
I was in San Antonio hotel I was at
hotel Emma though what's funny you're
reading you made me blood red mad I said
I went to Hotel Emma has this insane
Library I went in the library sent
behind the video I like that hey I'm so
Talent hated it Mark Mark was involved
in that I like yeah Mark was it Mark was
involved in that whoa cat
okay
cat leaves the show and she starts
[ __ ] crushing it there you go doing
her thing all right doing her thing love
her
um have you talked to Stevie uh he came
to my show
um he never calls me
maybe he's mad at me I don't know what I
did but
he's not mad he's he's swamped I know
he's swamped because that yeah he came
to my show in Ontario I saw him Ontario
right Mark yeah yeah yeah and then he
was gonna come to Boston
hmm
scary place it's called class peasants
yeah hit it very good
now because great book hold on go back
go back go back go back hold on go back
after the first thing I don't refresh it
let me see something let's see if
daddy's read any of those books I'm
sorry I have to do this I've read
Nabokov
he's not a big firm
uh I can't read that deceiving women I
think I said deceiving women
I've read the intellectuals oh deceiving
women by Bill Cosby that's cool yeah uh
okay I read animal mom too oh [ __ ] I've
read some of those books all right keep
going
Brandon I've been looking for you
everywhere what are you doing drinking
in the library no they made me that robe
[Music]
and you were down the lobby in that
[ __ ] road
Meathead let's get a mental workout as
well those are Jay's glasses
they were awful and you're drinking type
of thing it is new
it's noon it's early for people like you
oh you're an alcoholic no I'm not it's
it's 9pm in Calcutta India that's random
it's true okay well it turns out that
Shakespeare Tiger thick go hand in hand
don't be Preposterous I don't even think
that's Shakespeare Brendan
oh [ __ ]
what was that book I had some random I
just grabbed one some random [ __ ]
book I like that commercial photography
books yeah I was getting books yeah and
then Tiger's thick because San Antonio
is a big Mark Texas big for us so we're
in all the specs out there so Houston's
this week and then uh I'm gonna
appearance at the specs the big specs
downtown Houston noon to two on Saturday
North Carolina for me Comedy Zone come
so you can come try the tiger thick
thick boy Squad will be there we'll have
samples teas merch everything beautiful
yes can be fun
selling whiskey and merch maybe I should
get on some merch
that's not my thing no wait how long are
we going to release the uh
kid shirts let's do Abby Kenny Fight
Club that'd be fun I just need to get on
it it'll be fun yeah but you're not
going to get on it are we we're not
going to do it not be done for that are
we going to do it yeah that one's easy
because we already have good designs no
we should but we need to do the
originals that's what I mean yeah yeah
this picture not the new one yeah yeah
the original
it's so weird Brian had his uh wedding
celebration and then I'm in my hotel
room I forget what time it was at and
then I sent it to uh Brian said man
we've been doing a hot second my man
it's true dude that's the original
that's such a good one it was so good
people started selling it and like that
that's when you were fighting dude yep
yeah people started making copies of it
started making fake ones
yeah not great yeah let's get that going
so we know it's going good those are
good yeah those are good I'll do that
for sure I'm on it be [ __ ] I'll get on
it yeah I wanna I wanna start wearing
those on stage yeah I was in my hotel
late man because I have to get up at 5am
you know when you have to absolutely
can't stop I hate it so much I have
anxiety I hate it so my bed was so
comfortable you know I was watching
Hellboy such a good movie from the start
fun I don't know I was watching how boy
had my whiskey there yeah well I did
when you're pumped up after your shows
so I'm trying to go to bed impossible
it's two o'clock that's why sometimes I
don't fight it sometimes like this is
what it is just as long as your body's
resting yeah it is what what it is yeah
you're not gonna get sleep so then I
maybe got two three hours sleep went to
the airport landed and took my kids
straight to Malibu I can't do that
because I'm so tired and I can't sleep
on the plane so what I'll do is I'll
I'll yeah I can't sleep I'll get my
sleep in and then I'll then I'll be
present well I can't I my thing is if I
stop then I'll pass that so I just don't
stop I don't sit down or sleep we just
came up keep going and then we get back
at four and I passed out for like an
hour oh yeah my girl's like you better
wake everyone I'm gonna sleep tonight
Jesus Christ
uh everybody getting sick last time out
on San Antonio and I said that green
room right there I've just been on
Covert I go long-term side effects that
green room right there is where I got
covered and then we were on the front
page of their uh San Antonio Express the
main newspaper I said your newspaper
wants to put me on the front cover it
was like I would say uh L.A kamine
brings kova to San Antonio I'm like nah
[ __ ] you guys gave me coven I got
covered here yeah I remember that bird I
remember the all our friends were there
were in The Green Room this is that
bright list before anybody really had it
yeah we had people telling shut down
touring and then you and I were in The
Green Room I looked at him like a chance
to get covert here well because I got an
alert on my we had 400 people waiting
and I got an alert on my phone saying we
were in The Hot Spot literally of the
United States we're all dancing and I
was like
man like one of those things bam on your
phone I was like nah that's fine and
then we got it then we got it and people
were so upset they call the super
spreaders people didn't know really you
know it wasn't that big of a deal but
back then we just didn't know people
were so mad [ __ ] off so man and your
Shadow band to this day yes I believe
that oh yeah yeah they were not happy
Elon could just buy Instagram that'd be
fantastic see what he's doing on Twitter
it's good news for creators why because
he got on there he had a whole
discussion on there they wrote a whole
article about it he goes I want to make
Twitter the new hot spot for Content
creators so he goes he was talking to
some big YouTuber and he goes what's
YouTube's cup when you post uh content
he's like 55 percent he only goes we'll
beat that so right now here's we're
gonna have it so you can post uh two 42
minute videos at a time which is great
for podcasts and stand up like you post
a special on there now monetize it why
he's like we're gonna beat YouTube he's
like let me get to work on it usually
you know he runs with that yeah and then
what I love too because with the blue
check you know I still have questions
about it I don't know what's going on
there
um with the blue check anyone can get
blue check if you pay eight dollars you
know so it's like if someone to make a
fake chain account they could do it and
just get verified then people don't know
if actually Chan it's not let's say
they're spreading hate but what he did
is anybody that's impersonating somebody
who's a blue check you get banned so
there's been a few guys who were
impersonating Elon or other people in
their banned right away wow you know
with facial recognition and stuff now
you can start getting you know you can
verify a lot easier nfts all that
technology is making it easier to be
yeah but Twitter doesn't have that and
there's no face recognization on that so
anyone can do it but he's like well the
deal is if you if you're not that person
you're verified we're going to pay any
for life so people get banned right now
like that even Klein from H3 was
mimicking Elon band he was yeah he got
banned like yesterday or today really
yeah AOC you did something she got
banned what yeah
yeah are you serious oh yeah
yeah
who is Ethan Klein I don't know who he
is he's a big podcaster
and on Twitter for mocking Jesus so he's
like I'll just mimic Elon elon's like
all right cool and then ban him whoa and
is he a big does that yeah yeah he's a
big platform HD yeah
but mess with the bull get the hornsies
oh he's suspended
oh so he's making fun well you know
Jimmy Kimmel was really disappointing he
goes I followed you when you were the uh
he [ __ ] goes I followed you when you
were the uh the electric car guy and now
I've watched you become a full-blown
piece of [ __ ] well I told you I think
Jimmy Kimmel could remember he's from
the man show
but he did blackface of Karl Malone but
now he's the voice of reasoning for the
left and remember his entire Show's
tanked because he's promoting Paul
Pelosi conspiracies but he wasn't he
just retweeted something he saw and Eli
if you're going to Elon Musk for your
news you're not he's he's basically
he's basically the close thing you have
to Iron Man he's that but he's also
silly on there yeah the stuff he says
isn't of work Kimmel was always silly
why is he being a dick because B is my
point because he has so much so many
skeletons in his closet one of his best
friends Adam Carolla who's like you know
based like us Jimmy Kimmel has so many
skeletons he did blackface Karl Malone
notice now this has come up he's been in
the face of cancer culture he wants
people me too all that [ __ ] and then I
think he has a deal or somewhere like
you better go hard in the paint so he
said he's lost half of his audience his
ratings are completely tanked because
his entire monologue was about shooting
on Trump right so he's made a his career
not he didn't make his career but since
he got to this big platform he's just
started going hard on the pain on
politics and cancel culture and all that
stuff yeah he has so many skeletons
closet I feel they're like you better
play ball dude or we're gonna point this
much so if you have a point of view
that's fine but to call somebody a piece
of [ __ ] on on Twitter is just be Beyond
The Pale well it's like so if Elon Musk
is a piece of [ __ ] who creates how many
jobs and creates a product everybody
loves boom and and it's also just a also
a symbol of what's possible in terms of
taking risk PayPal founder it's also
immigrant and an immigrant and all that
and if he's a piece of [ __ ] then where
what what is Jimmy Kimmel called
murderers rapists then what is Jimmy
kimball who's done more for society Elon
Musk or Jimmy Kimmel
[ __ ] what are you better than that he's
better than that he's not though not
lately and I love Jimmy he's my favorite
host until he went super political I was
like what do you I don't come here to
hear your take on I promise even Jimmy
Kimmel came out recently was like I've
cut my audience my ratings are down I've
got mines in half because I went so hard
on the pain on Trump yeah we're sick of
it dude I'm not even the biggest drum
guy but all you're gonna do bad on Trump
fine just be smart and funny about it if
you want to go bad on Elon then go be
smart about it but when you say
somebody's a p piece of [ __ ] that's a
[ __ ] up thing to do it's beyond civil
discourse and it's actually fighting
words it actually makes me it's like
you're drawing lines in the sand and and
you're actually drawing lines in the
sand that can really get spun out of
control it doesn't matter though Jimmy
kimmelo's nothing can pretty Elum no no
I mean especially on Twitter I mean it's
insane man that he's lost me as a fan
for now I've lost me a long time ago but
I'm not mad if you're gonna roast Trump
but have a unique take every night five
days a week that's that's your whole
narrative I don't know Jimmy I know a
sister and I love her she's great uh
she's a comic old school Jimmy was
[ __ ] old school great he was a guy
he's great Adam Carroll is still to this
day his best friend oh really yes
they're close that's surprising think
about it I mean polar opposite yeah
polar opposite well it's it's not even
that like we're just reasonable people
like I'm I'm in the I'm in the middle I
heard Trump's going to announce his uh
presidency today wow A little birdie
works for him told me that um
I haven't heard anything so we'll see
it's interesting Newt King which did um
Newt Gingrich was terrible an old school
yeah are you a lizard guy are you a
lizard smart guy been an old school
Republican created the the contract with
America considered one of the three
Republicans Ronald Reagan
Newt King Richard created the contract
with America and realize that anything
decided to that so his argument is Trump
and here's why but he's been following
politics for so long and he was he goes
bad on the uh Republican parties like a
lot of them are managers so Herbert
Walker Bush George W bush managers
managers not Visionaries and and Elon I
mean Newt Gingrich said anything we do
you know if you want to try to do prayer
in school or any of that stuff just know
that the media is going to take anything
you do
and it's going to like even if you're
pro-business as opposed to pro-big
government or if you say that the
biggest success they had was welfare
reform that Clinton signing the thing
because it was so popular because it was
like get people off dependency and into
the payroll and then when they're
working they will pay taxes and we'll
get we'll have a boon we'll have a lot
and for the first time they balance the
budget which we're so far away from but
they actually balanced the budget so he
was talking about but he said that Trump
was a disrupter because he knew how the
billionaire Elites in New York worked he
knew how politics giving money to both
sides he was in construction he spoke
like he spoke like a blue-collar guy so
all the academics none of the new people
like that all the [ __ ] Elites they're
not around that they were like this
guy's trying to destroy us yeah but
destroying them but also the reason he
gets so much backlash from all the media
too is he doesn't play the game he's not
compromised no he's not and and also he
had a really comprehensive foreign
policy he was talking about this is new
cameras but he said that he knew that
that we were footing the bill for NATO
so since World War II everybody in the
world has been able to trade on the Open
Seas without any worry that somebody's
going to hijack their ships or [ __ ] with
them why the United States literally the
United States is responsible for all the
Seas security
within the world
Ethiopians say hold my [ __ ] we took care
of that so so still that was a little
thing but for the most part our Navy
polices since World War II has policed
the Open Season and so other countries
don't have to pay for security that's a
huge thing
and so he said wait a minute this is
costing us a [ __ ] load of money other
countries should contribute and it was
things like that yeah that were very
unpopular to other countries but
certainly fair and made a lot of sense
the first guy but also why do you get so
much blowback
because those politicians in the seat
before they were getting benefits off
making those relationships with those
other countries Trump goes and goes I
don't give a [ __ ] what they're offering
no no we're gonna keep it here in
America and people got so upset yeah
which he also said China is first guy to
say China's ripping this country off
like that's that's crazy it's nothing
though I know because uh average
Americans said that's what we think
their Trade Practices were unfair and he
called it out and it was very popular
and all that stuff so it but but when
you do that when you disrupt and you
speak that way and you're insulting it's
not the most professional yeah which I
wish you would clean that up but I'll
tell you people people don't like it
people don't like it it's me instant
yeah it's a very good interview did I
send it to you I sent it to Rogan it's a
very good Jordan Peterson and oh it's
Jordan Peterson yeah on his podcast with
you recently yes boy I'd love to hear
those two really really good really good
and you get a real sense of what's wrong
with the Republican Party what's right
with the Republican Party well how it's
changed but also you got a real sense of
inside politics yeah I would love that
yeah really really interesting
and that was the newest one with Jordan
it does newt 80 or something and does
the talking I'll say something
interesting too he goes you know um he
said they're talking about why is the
left so why are they into like having
three-year-olds determine their what's
the point with that they're you know
their sex and all that and all the stuff
pronouns goes
well I think uh the left and especially
the elites are suffering from mental
illness I think they're actually crazy
and that was his diagnosis but he said a
lot of this these Generations because
the two generations that just came about
they were schooled by parents who
thought that they had to make their
children like them
you're a parent my kids have to like me
he said I came from a generation
different where if your teenager didn't
like you you were doing your [ __ ] job
it's more of a respect I ain't your
friend I'm your father I ain't your
friend I'm your mother and why because
this is how it goes because the world's
a kick in the nuts I love you enough to
be a bigger kick in the nuts there was a
balance there is there's a balance there
is I'm not saying that look I'm wrong
but I'm not saying it's all right I'm
not the guy no I'm always criticized
because my son can I love him so much
that we just [ __ ] around yeah my
daughter's already hijacked me she's
already in terms of discipline she's
already won I just can't do it myself
we're the same I'm only disciplined when
it comes to school and sports outside
that my son makes me we are the same you
know I'm pretty loosey-goosey you know
he just makes me laugh dude but as far
as back in the day it's also like it
almost was a thing where it was
acceptable for the dads not to really
put in time it's just that was they
would work nine to five you're dead
newspapers your dad worked you can copy
Russell newspapers his dinner you go to
bed that can't be the best way they said
first one out the door last one in you
ever hear Sebastian maniscalco's uh a
[ __ ] uh thing on that no Italian
father from Chicago I think immigrant or
at least like first generation he said
what the [ __ ] is this my sons my friend
we're best friends I didn't meet my
father formally until I reached puberty
or no he goes until I was 18 or 19 he
goes my father was first one out last
one home he was always at work I met him
I think he goes hey I'm sorry manuscript
that was people did that work out for
you
it can be the right thing to do like
spend time with your kids is everything
you know but back then that's what they
thought was right you know what it was
back then it was more of a fear of your
parents there's more respect the
greatest Generation right they did all
right
yeah you're right they did all right for
Dad's that's when you don't have their
problems yeah I don't know I don't know
but as long as you know your dad loves
you right but I I spend every waking
minute I can with the kids yeah it's
just the different times are different
and also back then right it was like
nine to five worked for the man like
there's a lot of entrepreneurs there
wasn't obviously social media there was
other ways of making means like as far
as money especially a creative it was
just a different time I I can see my son
itself they also dressed a whole lot
better they're more discipline oh yeah
you dressed my father still my father
still if you if you show up in sloppy
clothes especially to like a wedding or
a party oh no you got a pro he's like
I'll call people at my shows like
somebody I mean it was in shorts ago
shorts huh yeah man
yeah date with your wife or shorts yeah
Alexander you don't have a problem with
that she's like no I told him like what
are you doing dude yeah what are you
doing my son my son bore himself a tie
and a suit 11 years yeah I I won't let
my kids leave the house in sweats no and
they're like why Dad I'm like you have
respect for yourself dude starts at a
young age there's a discipline to it 100
and you by the way you feel differently
in acting we used to always say like
when you wear shoes if you're playing a
character and you show up in like soft
sold shoes versus bespoke leather shoes
you know where like their their dress
shoes you're going to play that
character differently it actually
changes the way you walk feel move speak
it really does Jeffrey Tambor always
talks about how he couldn't figure out
this character and sound this is
actually [ __ ] but it's interesting
couldn't figure out the character and he
found the shoes and they were tight and
they hurt his feet a little bit but they
were what the English wear and they were
[ __ ] I mean you're talking about the
souls and the leather and he goes he put
those on and he goes oh I got it yep I
gotta have this so so they always talk
about the English aristocracy this is
going to sound crazy but
when you sat down on a chair during the
day sir and I don't care if you were 80.
you did not
sit in a comfortable chair you sat in a
straight back chair you did not Lounge
lounging in a comfortable chair was when
you had a brandy after dinner after all
that then you withdrew to a special room
where you allowed yourself to recline
not in front of people maybe close
friends there's something to be said
about that because it's also like now
today we're dude like it is what it is
whether left or right like the America's
just soft yeah it's like so soft when
you think about like imagine back in the
day like you're dead my dad Grinders
nine to five
there was even an idea to work from home
right Zoom call right and then if you're
a zoom call and you're just doing your
jammies all day taking [ __ ] zooms
yeah you're still getting your work done
but it's just it's not the same that's
right well I was always talked to Tucson
my mother and my father said when you're
at dinner at a restaurant and somebody a
woman comes to the table you can call a
chauvinist I don't give a [ __ ] yeah you
fart you get the [ __ ] up you stand men
stand up yeah I come from that so every
man stands up you stand up and you stay
standing when when she comes to the
table it's just because the Queen of
England whatever it is
it's interesting man protocol protocol
and manners are we've lost a ton of that
big things
I just feel like we've lost time in
America's just in everything way too
comfortable yeah my girl's family all
the men raised that way yeah every one
of them every [ __ ] one East Coast
what's really weird too is a heavy
percentage of wrestlers and all raised
in in East Coast yeah Pennsylvania uh uh
New Jersey oh wrestling's all about
respect oh dude well when they talk to
my father when they would all the men so
her cousins are all young young men but
raised with that [ __ ] that discipline
every one of them the table manners when
they sat with my father like this ramrod
straight and yes Mr Callen yes sir a lot
of that it was pretty wild it was like
yeah that's cool we got some discipline
yeah it's dope I want you to do that
with me and here's why because you're my
Elder no because you the three of you
guys are younger and I'm I'm well you
have to kill you and children
uh 45 he's 45. 10 years
so you sit sit up straight around me
sit up straight back make your back
young I'm young I can sit like this no I
don't like you yeah you're a [ __ ] I'm
young and I'm on Tick Tock slouchy Sally
no no I'm gonna sit like this I'm gonna
Vape
I'm a vape get on Tick Tock and get
FaceTime put both the soles of your feet
on the ground put your hands
sit straight I'm a big wig Ram Rogers
and I treat you I show my disrespect by
just lounging
I'm Lounge I got a [ __ ] text from
Dalia I don't know where it just said
hey [ __ ] so I called him up my mama
wanted to go to his show because she was
at the Paramount Theater in Denver she
wanted she loves Chris and I told Chris
like hey my mom needs to take he said
yeah I got him and my mom because her
legs can't go she broke her leg oh no
she had surgery it's like not healing
great spiral fracture ouch that's a big
boy surgery yeah that's bad not good
dude not good buddy well yeah I'm sad I
missed your celebration it's weird when
it's so weird you and I were talking and
I was like I miss you man wish I was
there in [ __ ] San Antonio and then
also you know your phone brings up I
iPad or the iPhones Apple has his like
throwback it was like you said what it
said November 2015 it was you and me on
stage in uh Manhattan crazy
and I said that to Brian we've come a
long ways my man we've been at it quite
some time sometime quite some time quite
some time yeah a while here we are that
was early final kid days remember that
yeah my my mother-in-law
had her necklace and then she had her
engagement ring and her wedding ring 30
years
stolen the Rings disappeared from your
party yeah
and this is my wedding and we looked
everywhere and we were like who could
have stolen these [ __ ] rings and I
put a damper on things because they're
like who's a kleptomaniac because that
you know it's all your friends kids by
accident who the [ __ ] knows no no one
steals up she didn't lose them she left
them in a room
dementia found them in no she found
Smite now we found him in her purse oh I
was like okay well that's frustrating
yeah man she started accusing the only
black guys at the party y'all hey
there weren't any black
sorry I knew that but we had I knew that
I had Koreans she only accused the
Tanner people Ah that's all yes I think
it was the workers that that's well I
did you no did you get a little loose
did you let yourself go I can't remember
the time I let myself I I let myself go
and then I have a very rough sense what
was the food though
um trying to see how much I missed I'll
say you can whiskey puppies how dare you
we had paella from scratch
who made it though a very special
company that makes oh but I'm talking
about our boy from Magic Bullet set it
up no my girl did how was the music let
me get to the paella okay yeah I'm just
checking I want to see how much I missed
man I love paella no no
how about the paella because they were
giant trays if this guy made it like
outside from scratch and it was [ __ ]
ridiculous it was you didn't post any
pictures right
I don't like posting pictures about my
my personal life that way no I open
myself up to
[ __ ] faces that make me angry but
there's us right here
well I like you guys look at that here's
what you're a gay couple we are gay
couple look at this girl by the way go
back oh man
come on Sam warms my heart come on but
yeah Sam is the best and um
there's there's A.G and Andy stuff
they're awesome the great Andy stump
what a great guy right
did you just meet Andy chin oh you met
him before yeah yeah Legends so smart
Legends funny guy too super funny yeah
oh yeah that's great smart as [ __ ]
I wish I was there man that bumps me out
I know I knew it but the magic mind you
guys did he'll have dinner for us yeah
and then walk alone Shane's gonna throw
us to dinner yeah and then you me Chris
our girls that'll be fun let's do that I
would love it can we do that yes 100 we
can we want to do it in Malibu where do
you want to do it yeah do it at his
house I want the same dancing I want the
same Pappy the whole thing magic mind
everywhere okay for sure fix your grass
before I come over right yeah right show
a little respect really yeah all right
you're getting too soft oh respect damn
yeah but they played badminton over
there oh my God okay that's a bad but
that's a bad angle right there that's
behind the barge I see I see brown
patches dude yeah
that's I know oh no he has kids
I mean down bad lawn well that's I hate
to go battle them that's not that's just
that's not the house he spends that much
time at you understand yeah God's other
houses no I know he does but come on
buddy we can put a little more funds who
defunded the yard who'd have funded
let's get a little fertilizer on that
but there's a it's an area where you
play volleyball and badminton so maybe
it's unacceptable when you when you ride
when you ride Turf hard like I do in
sports yeah you're gonna scuff some [ __ ]
up
you're going to create some divots in in
the grass
yeah I guess man
I I enjoyed watching my son make uh Luke
rockhold and Company laugh their asses
let's see did you Sundance no my son my
son has figured out that he's a comedian
and and and I'm watching him
um figure out like he'll he'll push the
envelope pull back that didn't work he's
done to the line he readjust his
approach yeah he is a good comment he is
like literally like a a student of the
game it's so he was in a suit too and a
suit and and your daughter came yeah but
making people fall yeah my daughter my
daughter in high heels she's a
full-grown woman my daughter looks 30.
bro I haven't seen her in a while I
haven't seen this so crazy I haven't
seen her since lockdown since at the gym
and then when you were at uh yeah first
thing you said I walked away who the
[ __ ] is this yeah you're like oh well
you're a full-grown woman she was eating
Taco Bell I was like what the [ __ ] yeah
it's insane she's a 14 year old and
she's five nine super tall I remember
when you filmed your special in Chicago
that's when I last saw your KIDS sprout
it's so big now isn't it weird Sun's
tallest [ __ ] now they're both going to
be really tough and it's so strange yeah
we don't see someone that says oh yes
big kids yes
and I can't remember Bill the manager
there's great they gave me that thick
boy robe because I always complained
about the robes not fitting they changed
the coffee because when I was like my
only issue within the coffee sour they
change their coffee beans now they offer
that same coffee and a dark roast yeah
you gotta have a dark the best tacos in
my [ __ ] life there oh man like the
food's so great you could live there I
could live there when I have a
restaurant when I leave there they do I
got sad because that for the reason that
place reminds me of me and you because
we found it together yeah and then I
just always stay there yeah and then you
were having your party I was by myself
on Saturday night I know [ __ ] I know
that's a bummer man
I [ __ ] love that place
it's just so unique man I actually I'm
gonna have a party twice a year with my
closest friends [ __ ] it I'm gonna have a
party twice here
it says probably 20 parties that's it
before I die I'm gonna for real time for
10 more years I'm I'm for real gonna
spend money to have my closest friends
together I have it catered and just have
everybody get and do it at Magic Bullet
South magic mine don't say Magic Bullet
don't say magic book get better about it
dude that's the Cradle get better at
names well there's anything you're magic
we'll do it Magic Mike's house magic
mind Magic Mike mind that's right James
Bashar James magic mom well James my
friend now
hey you know how it goes hey you know
how you know how it goes it's my friend
you know like meet my friend like oh
he's way funner right no don't be cool
and then they text me like hey dude now
you're making me mad please be cool
sorry buddy
sorry pal yeah we should do a party
twice a year
I I I'm really sorry find the kid
palooza well because why why not
otherwise you wait till what everybody's
too busy [ __ ] off dude yesterday take a
weekend have a party I agree we should
do 100 I'm down
have a whiskey bar have all that [ __ ] I
mean we'll just have tiger thicks and
you can shove everything else up your
old pipe why would I put it in my pipe I
don't know why not my [ __ ] right out
yeah try it it's funny uh when he got
home yesterday from the car show uh the
hangovers on from the start it's such a
good movie and I was like oh this is
Brian's part my girl goes you know every
time this move to London you say that
every single time I say I don't know why
I get so excited she's like every I know
I know it's this part oh yeah all right
well
I love that
all right Tim what do you got buddy
all right let's get a good weekend so
Saturday you went to Brian's his girl's
a smoke shop relax bro I won't relax
let's put too much pressure she stepped
out of a [ __ ] movie dude like like
you know unicorn yeah crazy Rich Asians
where they had like the most beautiful
woman in the world like that's I know it
is right but but it's like she belonged
in that movie as the hot girl at the
party am I wrong about that am I being
or or for better example maybe she's the
Asian with green eyes from Big Trouble
in Little China
doesn't have green eyes she's from
Mongolia that's how rare it is yeah but
she's just she's just [ __ ] gorgeous
and seemed very classy marry her
this girl no oh this is oh boy well yeah
back in the 80s though she is First Team
all batty three nights
oh wait what is that no [ __ ] I think
she's the girl also from
um rush hour no uh oh dude oh she was so
hot
look her up she's in another movie she's
gorgeous
yeah that body is is they but they're
back then because the white girl had
green eyes too so he wanted to get with
both of them yeah she's like from
Singapore but she's Irish I don't know
yeah she's greasy yeah I don't know I
don't [ __ ] know dude everything's a
disaster low pan
big trouble on Little China never saw it
by the way oh my God how dare you of the
poster in my [ __ ] room
yeah
the supposed to make a second I guess
the Rock's in it real disappointing
damn they didn't hover on the credits
other C's right Mao Yin is that her I
think this is the one yeah
who is she in
let's see filmography
okay she hasn't worked in quite some
time
oh you probably know her from Sharky's
Machine 1981 1981. okay she's a little
too old
oh you know her from tingers
89
[ __ ] detective extra large okay sounds
like she had some dark arts detective
extra large I think it's called the
lover let me see it though she's not in
that the movie The Lover you're about to
it's gonna be a different Asian girl
racist
oh you're thinking Jane March this girl
probably thinking chain Mark she was
super super pretty oh no I no Chin go
it's it's you're thinking of Frederick
uh minger that's who I'm thinking about
yeah Frederick
the mother that's I can't believe I
remembered the lover yeah when when you
see her in that movie when she was
younger it's got some teeth on her huh
don't bite me girl no I can't no dude
oh Bruce Willis with the awful goatee
that was his girl for a while yeah
that's a prime Bruce Willis yeah and
that's Prime whatever now she's not
Asian right right she's a mix of uh yeah
so here's the Chinese and something else
so here's the look at her face body is
what what changed everybody's everybody
was like what no she's fantastic they're
Jane Marsh Lover I Don't Know by the way
she might have been too young to talk
about here I don't want to get canceled
now here's the young man I was sure
about sure you were 17. now here's the
thing
now she's gorgeous I get that I was
talking about a straight up Asian girl
in big trouble little China and
completely diverted this thing and
basically a white push it to a white
girl
same girl yeah right sorry about that
all right Jim what do you got so you
went to his party Wilson you chin
just hung out
did you drink some of that whiskey dude
because you're a whiskey guy did you get
anything oh whiskey bar so Joseph yeah
you guys talk about how awesome is he's
super cool he was just like he's the
funnest guy he made me feel like the
most special person he'll take a a party
over and make sure oh yeah he's he's
John Belushi from Animal House but way
more classy yeah but he gave me the
shots of the he said it was like 40 000
whiskey whatever so we did shots
together it was amazing yeah so much fun
huh what you're on social media how do
you not post pappies the ball is a Pappy
I thought I want to be in the moment you
know well I respect that okay Daddy like
guys still redeem yourself 45 year old
chain coming out yep but definitely want
to take picture of Brian
um together you know we have fights
coming up not being cool if that thing
was presented by Tiger thick I could
have sent all the bottles I didn't even
think about it yeah it would have been
nice I did probably Marcus wedding did
you yeah I would have done that when I
told I completely forgot I saw there's
gonna be magic mine with uh vodka or
something oh we got a five thousand you
actually bet on some stuff no no it's
not happening well it's happened this
Saturday it is yeah it's a Saturday UFC
281 mess Square Garden now now hold on
before let me go over our bet hold on
you have Izzy Alex Pierre right I love
sucking Alex oh I love his nope you're
out Izzy's watch this he's a fan I love
Daniel I love it he's I love it
I just want to take that bed because I
want to create some drama yeah now we
have Carlos barza Zhang waylay right now
the here's now we're getting to the
nitty-gritty yeah Dustin Poirier Michael
Chandler [ __ ] man that's our boys [ __ ]
dude you can't do this to me
okay here's the thing I refuse to pick I
love both of them I wish they weren't
fighting but they have to damn it it's
it's a very good fight no [ __ ] now now
let me ask you this is at 70 or 55. 55
obviously okay now here's the thing
um [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um why are you asking me do I have what
do you mean you just said let's talk
about the fights this is the toughest
one to pick this is this is a that's
important as a slight favorite
like minus 170. I mean this is a insane
now now there's a lot um predicated on
this bike because at 155 whoever loses
you can buy Q back online okay I'm gonna
ask you some questions like like a
nightclub I'm gonna ask you some
questions before I make my choice don't
make them stupid
who would you say is the better Grappler
uh straight Jiu Jitsu or like wrestling
Fourier probably Jiu Jitsu poor is a
black bone Jiu Jitsu yeah that's fine
and then uh Chandler's wrestling
pedigree and explosiveness makes them
the better who puts who on their back
first Chandler if if there's a
takedown's Chandler shooting on pour it
okay yeah but then when it gets down
there Porey has the advantage what are
submissions would it be would it be
weird to say the Chandler is the more
explosive athlete right now yes yes
um does he pray in the pocket is go to
his record turn look at his right let me
educate Brian he's a hell of a boxer so
his his deal he's good at everything
right he's good at everything he's a
hell of a [ __ ] he'd be Connor twice
Dan hooker Les khabib but then he beat
Max Holloway runs too much for Max Eddie
Alvarez Justin gaichi fight of the Year
Anthony Pettis he'll put it on you Jim
Miller he's beat some of the big boys I
know
I really want to pick out of Brian here
and now Dustin does make a some great
hot sauce b a good bourbon yeah I love
everything about Dustin love everything
about it now now here's our friend
Michael Chandler right now he's he's uh
you know he's foreign
four fights but he's fought the who's
who he fought Dan hooker no punk knocked
him out and two minutes 30 seconds one
of the best knockouts then he fought
Oliveira right he could have won that
fight first round 10A they ended up
losing that in the second round then
Justin gaichi fight of the night also
fight of the year last year Crazy by
most people crazy so he has two losses
but boy there are there's some
entertaining losses and then obviously
the front kick Spartan Kick the 21st and
disrespectful that it is what it is yep
well so currently right now who you
taking
this is a terrible Channel I also found
a guy named Sydney outwall which is
pretty cool name that's in Bellator
clearly I am I mean these guys are
you're on the hot seat I'm on the hot
seat and I hate it I hate having to pick
this come on give me more time nope hold
on
yeah
I'm gonna tell you why I'm I'm going to
some prayer here's why here's why
Chandler
is going to have a very wide stance
Dustin's going to kick that [ __ ] calf
a lot okay
now he's got to be careful that doesn't
does that what about challenge got to be
very careful Channel doesn't time that
and throw now if there's anybody that
can sit in the pocket and have you catch
his elbows and hands it's [ __ ] Dustin
okay he can protect there's a reason why
he's a slight favorite yes and Dustin
has been uh and and then
look Chandler is a hell of a wrestler
but if there's anybody that can catch
you on the ground when they're on their
back it is Dustin
um
well Jesus Christ yeah I'll slit you out
no no I've had it no I know not enough
but I'm gonna go I'm only gonna go with
Dustin Poirier because they're feeling
better
I know him better really yeah so I know
both well I'm emotionally I'm not
thinking I just wanted to get a pick out
of here Chandler's awesome and I love
him and I won't be mad if either one
wins because
it doesn't pray
because of the low kicks and because of
his Close Quarters combat his CQB
and and against the the fence and the
clinch I think both of them kind of
stalemate each
other's more aggressive more powerful
probably the stronger guy his wrestling
could be an issue his power he
definitely has the advantage I think
poirier's a more well-rounded fighter
it's a great fight who has more
who has more Wars and more weather on it
that's important for sure yeah for
that's significant yeah it's all the
time we don't we don't know but does the
party is a legend it doesn't be ages
uh it's more it's something about age
it's more miles
Dustin party has been fighting UFC for
everything but but I have to say that
our boy Chandler has also taken I mean
he's been he's been engaged forever
fight and that well I verified that
takes something out of you a little bit
could I mean you know Chandler's older
by three years handsome [ __ ] guy yeah
he is I'm gonna that's also so so you're
talking about that's my favorite fight
on the card the same amount of
they have the same amount of whatever
experience uh wear and Tim wear and tear
uh so far I'd say poorie has a little
more still fighting at the top of that
I'd say has a little more also Port has
been fighting a higher level for a lot
longer yeah well not saying Bell Tour is
not a high level it ain't UFC that's 800
yeah remember does brain fought Connor
when he's at 45 the selling board Conor
McGregor is a hell of a boxer and Dustin
will stand there and just so Michael
Chandler's not going to give him
channel has more power than both of them
yes he does that's a challenge explosive
that's a huge factor and Chandler's also
right now like the Golden Boy for the
UFC channel is thought he was either
going to get uh Nate Diaz or Conor
McGregor I talked to him I'll see when
they announced with me when they
announced he's like you got it and then
the rumors of Dustin Porter came out
because he has been good at first it's a
great way he's fishing for a big dog and
he got one in this the only thing the
reason I'm not picking obviously these
guys lose because if Chandler does
probably lose it change the trajectory
of their careers because at 55 it's so
deep there's so many young lines there
it's gonna be tough to get back to a
title shop for either one
fight either I'm
I'm I I think Chandler mocktail is a
interesting fight
listen up oh God are you getting your
knee pads out because you're ready to
suck off the day of your fannies hold on
calm down listen up
listen up let's sit up get your back
straight I'm bigwig get your back
straight when you talk to me I'm
chilling don't I don't want you to bring
this my locker I don't want you to bring
up Islam mockachev again okay now you
know I love Dustin okay so you're real
no take your ring off no you shut the
[ __ ] up
now Chandler what's Chandler going to do
with Market Jeff
is his power his explosive oh my oh he's
been knocked out right yeah yeah yeah
Channel just needs one baby that's right
shut up
don't bring up Mach Jeff again hey this
is this is Brian whenever I mention a
dagger standing
don't bring them they they're offended
by that don't bring them up again I want
you to know I never don't like that I
don't go like you like this uh line them
up here you're the better boys I don't
do it like that either that's not how I
would do it because that doesn't even
feel that good this is Brian I'm
walrusing this is you when you're
jacking off at night it's a dagestanding
[ __ ] bukaki film it's a walrus they
call that the walrus because they're all
too tough and they're all and they're
all in singlets
out there okay okay so don't bring up
Market Chef again but here's the thing
here's the thing do you want me to break
down the addisonia fight sure man okay
so you tell me it's so hard can you wait
yeah let me pee and then do it I'll
check my phone we're taking a break do
some research hey guys come see me this
weekend North Carolina Comedy Zone next
weekend I'm going to Addison Improv it's
good to go let's go all right let's do
this [ __ ] give it to me is he out there
then we'll move on here's here's what um
Izzy is one of the great Champions love
him and I think uh I think it'd be the
worst thing in the world for the UFC if
pajera wins yeah so I'm going to be
Pierre so I'm going to be rooting
secretly even though I have money up
here I'm rooting against Grand I think
yeah five or three five five five take
it easy
um
but
uh there are a couple things going on
one piara hits he's bigger stronger and
hits harder
and I think
um he's gonna press
he's going to press and how's that
worked out for every other high level
fighter that presses Izzy um
go ahead well it's a different kind of
press it's a different kind of press I
don't I think you can make the argument
actually that Izzy does most of his
damage when he is the aggressor not when
he is necessarily not when he is
necessarily not when he's necessarily
the uh back foot fighter okay okay well
that's right I I think
I would say no he gets knocked out some
finishes when guys press forward they
make mistakes not really
I would say I'd say for example Whitaker
was not about he he kicked him in the
head and knocked him out so actually if
you look at a lot of the actual damage
it's when he's moving forward you have
to take a chance against Izzy when they
open up take chances that's when he gets
finishes and the The Narrative on the
UFC and why they're having fight Pierre
because they know Pierre's going to
press the action force Izzy to fight yes
otherwise he just sit back because like
with the old Romero who didn't want to
engage yeah because he's like cool I'm
the champ I'm just going to sit here
yeah because he's not going to press the
actor he wants you to make mistakes on
four and that's when he knocks you out
yeah as soon as he's opening and you get
more tired then he'll press it but
initially he is he likes to have you
step into the park but so so here's what
I think I don't think is he takes a guy
like Pierre and I don't think Pierre is
afraid of Izzy's power when he's moving
back okay and I think he absorbs that
and then then it's then he's able to
land if he's pressing action I think
guys what's the only way Pierre's get
him yes I think two guys at that same
same size with Pierce High Level
kickboxing like that when he presses a
different kind of press and if he's able
to weather Izzy's backward movement and
Strikes now pure capitalized sure and
that's what you're going to say sure you
know nobody's ever been able to do that
right well I don't I would respectfully
say that no one that is he in the
Octagon hasn't fought anybody like Piera
in terms of their striking and that
level definitely the highest level and
also big also really really big very big
for the weight class he's not that much
bigger than his I believe he's stronger
and bigger a little bigger he's a big
boy big head he's you know big as he's
big you've been around him in person I
mean he's huge like everyone wants to
you know predicate on pier and this yeah
Pierre and his UFC fights obviously if
if you're new to Pierre and you just
watch Sean Strickland like Jesus Christ
man this guy's insane yeah he was hit in
his fights before this he got hit
several times yeah he was taken down
didn't do much on the ground but I don't
think we get much grappling so that
doesn't matter what and I think Izzy too
if you go back and watch the fight we
got knocked out when it's just
kickboxing was just six years years ago
I think five six years ago six years ago
Izzy's win that fight he's he's a more
technical Striker he's a better Striker
overall better Striker uh he doesn't
have the same power he's more technical
fighter he was winning that entire fight
based off technique and speed and
decided to play that dangerous game of a
shootout and Pierre has more power and
landed the punch that's it I we've never
seen Izzy ever again fight like the UFC
the only thing he came close to is
Kelvin gaslin he didn't up not beating
him which was to me top three
middleweight fights of all time agree
but I think Izzy has learned from that
and also Izzy is used to find 25 minutes
being the main event being the center of
attention Alex appears never fought 25
minutes has never come close to find
some of Izzy's caliber in mixed martial
arts this is his first fight on
Dimension at Madison Square Garden
big lights oh no hold on boat the
biggest lights yeah so we're gonna he's
gonna have to you took a good bet hey
he's gonna have to deal with those
butterflies he took a good bet and then
also oh you're you're banking this off
of busy from six years ago that's cute
no no I'm banking on no but that's what
most people are doing oh well he beat
him you know it's like okay
and then as he has coaching experience
at the highest level sure I think what
happens you want my prediction yes
Pierre is going to go forward yeah he's
not gonna touch it he's gonna get very
frustrated he's gonna be walking around
he's up probably three rounds of zero at
this point he's not gonna touch him he's
not going to touch him really he's gonna
be moving doing his thing he throws a
lot of smoke now so many more tools than
his Arsenal since last time they fought
peers can get very frustrated he's going
back to Corner he's going down three to
zero his corners and go dude this ain't
working bro we're gonna start going for
broke you gotta dying your Shield
really the problem is when you die in
your Shield against a guy like isn't you
rush in sure you get finished I think as
he knocks him out uh fourth or fifth
round really I think he finished him if
he doesn't finish him yeah he mops the
floor with him decision
Pierre doesn't touch him really you
think that Izzy's
kickboxing is at MMA yeah way back his
striking is higher level with four ounce
gloves on is he's a better a technical
fighter Hunter not even close I think
now not even close not even close no the
closest that those fights look I watched
those fights I don't know about that I
wouldn't say that I would say that was
six years ago I'm saying the MMA but
Pierre has been hasn't he been in the
game the kickboxing game since then this
isn't kickboxing B this is mixed martial
arts I understand he's lost one he's
been hit in most of his fights he's been
taken down
and these aren't high level guys right
his highest level guy fought was Sean
Strickland who was hand-picked and
engaged with him was supposed to Grapple
decided to oh I'm doing well in the
Striking game gets knocked out yep
you're dealing with a completely
different animal and I know the knock on
these boring stuff like that who who's
busy people I don't say that well you
don't I'm saying the fan base he doesn't
get finishes stuff like that and it's
not on Izzy he's already the champ you
got to take that belt first if you when
you come and this is why if I lose five
grand I want to yes I would love to does
he still hate you he texts me but um I
think Pierre's the perfect matchup and
that's why the UFC they're pushing
Pierre notice he went no no experience
no experience Sean Strickland win that
yo title shot if you give him anybody
else in the top seven he loses guarantee
it they can grapple yeah so you got to
save that nuts put him to Izzy that's
why he's a bad champion no he's gonna
hold the belt well that's a whole no I
think so short-sighted I mean and but I
literally think the UFC knows Izzy can
beat him he'll force him to fight to get
a Knockouts can build Izzy's star even
bigger because they know Pierre is not
going to sit back he's going to go For
Broke and get the best out of is he is
he in those first the first round two
rounds he's gonna be very dialed in very
focused it's not gonna be a whole lot of
action because remember he's lost him
twice I don't care who you are that's in
your mind says yeah so he's even watches
P's accused early on that's why I don't
see why you say it's a much better
Striker you're talking about MMA
striking yeah MMA at high level meaning
you've got to worry about a takedown but
I don't know it's Pierre's gonna it's
not even take down like let him fire
away is he as far as MMA goes is he
around circles what's the difference
the the the reach the distance the kicks
that like there's a lot of difference
and and then also don't get twisted
don't get twisted if it did become a
grappling match which I would not pay to
watch but if it did become Izzy's a much
better because he's got more experience
but I I but I think Izzy sits on the
outside wins based off points and I I
even think we're gonna get some booze
and then Pierre's coaching like all
right this ain't working dude we got to
go For Broke and as he takes advantage
of it
because I don't think Izzy everyone's
like well if Izzy want to he could have
a grappling bench I think in Izzy's
mindset he's like no no that's the easy
way out there's a reason why Izzy's can
be the best middleweight of all time if
he beat Sammy's up there right so I
think he's going no no I'm gonna show
you I'm better Striker than him he's
going to show you he's in our class
that's that's he's quicker more
technical more tools he doesn't have the
power though so Izzy can land you know
two to three shots and pure be fine pure
Lance won this thing's over that's right
and I always go with that oh no I always
go I go to the mortality because pure is
such a high level Striker as well and
listen I'm always late to get one guys
they gotta do a lot before I jump on
their bad wagon unless you're you know
unless you're [ __ ] home homeboy from
Penn State wrestler
um Bo Nichols but outside him it takes
like how late the game was I with
microchip
oh you guys were right well no but most
time people aren't sometimes people
don't sometimes those lights there's
competition those lights can change
things purest and experienced competitor
not at this level but he's an
experienced if he sometimes you get to a
level and you belong there like you're
exactly where you belong I and I'm not
ready to say Pierre belongs here at all
because Pierre if he didn't have this
backstory with is he oh Bubba you're
going through the [ __ ] Gauntlet
they're gonna get Paulo Costa you need a
[ __ ] uh Bronson yeah you're gonna get
Jared Canon
oh and if you get through them and you
ranked in the top three well then
there's a guy waiting for you who just
can't figure out a way to be dizzy his
name's Robert Whittaker yeah he's a
Nightmare Night sir Izzy's the best
matchup for Pia just happens to have
that backstory if they didn't have that
backstory correct this never happened
correct you know what Whittaker would do
to ask Pierre yeah Whitaker can wrestle
his ass off grab him he's fast bring him
to the ground yeah
that's right well that's why I think
Pierre will hold the belt for exactly 10
minutes if he wins this then he's an
automatic rematch there's automatic
rematch and so as I was saying in the
shop show chin it's very short-sighted
because I think UFC's Bank gun is he
winning but the the other side of this
coin is if Alex does knock out Izzy
right and then Izzy the automatic
rematch who's been running champ for so
long you have to give him that's the way
the UFC works so he's automatic rematch
let's just say he has Izzy's number to
your point he has Izzy's number it
knocks him out again
well you you then you got Robert
Whittaker in the in the shadows yeah
vittori you got Brian he kind of killed
the division in some ways it would just
be it's gonna rotate the belt and then
you're also killing literally I mean
since Nate Diaz and Conor McGregor's out
you're you're literally Rune and Jon
Jones out you're Izzy's your biggest
star yeah I have no because he's by far
your biggest star yeah so to me it's
short-sighted but it's interesting we're
talking about it he is your biggest star
100 all right Jim what do you got
all right this is a a robbery
in LA
in Hollywood West Hollywood and it's in
broad daylight too so this uh
this Tesla driver gets robbed I'll just
show you the video real quick
if it plays
got robbed in the middle of the middle
day just watch how everyone reacts here
too so Hollywood showing a man being
robbed at gunpoint running away from his
assailant only to be later run down by
the suspect's vehicle all right so he's
still chasing him and what do you want
is watch or something yeah whatever he
has but apparently the only thing he had
was a ring so they took his ring but
check this out just throw the ring and
go dude I know he just ran away so check
this out
this is the moment the crooks slammed
into the victims oh my God the man this
isn't broad daylight all these cars
around collapsing on the sidewalk watch
as one of the thieves forcefully he has
no shirt on and then drives away
man Johnny Depp let himself again wow
Hollywood that's really mind-blowing
that would happen there well it's good
that you survived and you had the video
now you know and that's a good thing
that you at least and the guy doesn't
have the gun there so he literally
chased him [ __ ] chase him around the
parking lot and then got in his car and
then ran him over in broad daylight no
one doesn't no one does anything Jesus
yeah
well they have guns that's why nobody
does that yeah yeah people assume they
have guns now and blind white yeah
anyways that was a they'll catch him I
hope
but sometimes
I mean especially the captions
especially if they get they can zoom in
they get uh his shirt off I'm sure the
license plate was there his tattoos and
license plate yeah oh he's got tattoos
yeah they catch him all right what else
we got
oh actually let's start with this one
because I have this too the Aaron Carter
you guys not he just passed away did
this surprise anybody no I'm being mean
but when well I was flying my girl goes
oh you won't believe this Aaron Carter
died I was like sorry our end card is in
a band right or his the brother he was
brother was Nick Carter Backstreet Boys
Aaron Carter was the younger brother but
he by the age I think of like 1314 he
came out with music and would open up
for Backstreet Boys and Britney Spears
and then when he was young he had a huge
uh track uh with Shaq and some other but
he like sold over a million records when
he's like 12 or 13. and then him his
brother had this this big fallen out
right like it it got nasty it got really
nasty I remember there's a lot of trauma
in that Cardiff yeah I became fascinated
with watching his interviews like in the
last year because he's almost like this
textbook like narcissist like hijacks
any conversation to bring it back to
some grandiose topic about himself but
obviously he's suffering a lot too but
it was just like this is really fat
because everything's like I don't get
enough credit I'm a genius like
everybody knows it's really me who's
like the first Justin Bieber all the
stuff
um and then he uh the face tattoos are
always a bad sign apparently yeah and
then he came out he's like pants sexual
it was a night let me see what he looks
like dude a good looking kid dude and
like good handsome dude yeah just a mess
he has just lost you know and then your
brother's [ __ ] you know Nick Carter
the Backstreet Boy says a hard shot to
come out of and then he had uh
you know he had a son he had issues with
baby mama and the conspiracy theories
his his last tweet was to Kanye West
because Kanye let's sit down talk man to
man it's like bro you think Kanye needs
you in his life right now his wife or
his late sister his late sister password
too yeah that family is tragic man it's
horrible dude at 25 34. horrible oh my
God the parents oh no the post by Nick
Carter with him and his brother young
you know because I got a brother it's
[ __ ] sad man wait let me see so look
at this poor kid I call these people I
always say they're the American lost he
had addiction problem you know he had a
big big addiction problem yeah obviously
obviously Hollywood can go [ __ ] itself
when you're posting pictures like that
though there's something going on I'm
sorry
I I just yeah he was doing a lot of
weird things with like I mean in
addition to the face hats but yeah he's
got he has a lot of time on his hands
who's that girl that was this baby mama
they have a kiddo together okay great
it's also uh there's the kiddo
don't pose like that yeah he's got big
problems that's a shame it's also it
just shows you it's like dude these kids
Stars man yeah it doesn't matter like
but also even experts I mean they're
studying a little more now but there's
no blueprint on how to handle them like
you think of the [ __ ] Justin Bieber
deals with Selena Gomez talks about it
it's like crazy [ __ ] he's poor kid just
the amount of tension like
humans humans humans aren't made to be
this famous like when you're that famous
and then also you have no one that
really relates to you well you have no
one who can say Hey [ __ ] face you're
being weird right now you know stop this
but so you have no one he was like the
provider for his family like all these
things that you do hear about it makes
you more sympathetic to like he had no
struck you know he didn't even have a
shot your little brother died
that's horrible that kind of pain
horrible I saw my father when he lost
his his brother and I don't care did he
lose him at a young age or no no man it
didn't matter it was his little brother
I know I'm just saying got a 77 but that
was a like it was 75
horrible horrible
um this right here is a shame because
you can tell he's struggling you know
yeah
yeah so after all this media attention
and headlines turns out Sylvester
Stallone's reconciling with his wife
this is a happy story he loves the [ __ ]
out of his wife and he loves the [ __ ]
out of his family yeah his kids are
great his daughters are great he loves
testers yeah he's his daughters are
[ __ ] awesome this guy this guy has
raised his family in Hollywood the right
way I don't know how he did it she grew
up on a farm yeah it was a lot of her
discipline and the way she runs 100 and
look at how she she's my age by the way
look at her she looks so much fun I know
she's incredible he's also he looks
better yeah he's she's also a Class Act
but this dude [ __ ] is one of the
daughters he loves his family so much
it's crazy but he said he says here I
think we could all take a freaking
advice on this he put uh I put work
before anything you know I've learned my
lesson yeah and I get it the dude's
doing non-stop movies like sometimes put
work out of my family it's attractive
mistake which won't happen again he yeah
his wife's probably sick of a [ __ ] it's
kind of like Tom Brady because you know
they're already on the rocks and then
you're supposed to retire and he said
why don't you go into football and she's
like all right I'm out dude like you
obviously don't care enough about the
family more than football the last
family he's like football I had a
conversation with him about exactly that
like he was like yeah I think I'm gonna
stop doing movies you know and I looked
at him and I was like well you know
we'll see these are said and then I saw
him like I don't know like three months
later and and I and he goes I'm doing a
movie kind of he looked all sheep's
because I got pulled back in I'm like
well you know you're you love doing it
you know but it is there's a price you
pay for all this [ __ ] oh yeah heavy
lights the crown for him happy lies the
crown what else you got and how's this
one work
uh so this guy in a nightclub in
Australia
comes out the cleaner been banging on
there for several minutes I guess and
the Duke is like fed up with it because
he's trying to get his Dizzle sizzled oh
he's in those girls oh no he was doing
his thing in there yeah exactly and the
cleaner is like bro I'm trying to get in
there uh I don't know if it was to clean
it up or break it up but he comes out
swinging
is cleaner because it looks like another
bro was trying to get in with a girl and
then the cleaners probably knocking and
then this guy's like hey dude I'm trying
to get my dick wet so he's knocking but
he's he's like busy yeah he's all
covered in blood I know so fast so I
guess there's a few ways to interpret
that like who's who's in the right here
the guy the cleaners in the right that
guy's a dick well no but the cleaner it
was in the Bro knocking on the door he
got in the fight the cleaner it looked
like he was trying to get in there and
this guy's in there getting his weiner
sucked and the other bro is trying to
get in there and then this guy was like
what the [ __ ] I'm sure the guy's talking
[ __ ] yeah that guy's a dick either way
but uh but also my only caveat with this
is if there's no foul play with the
ladies going in that bathroom and you
have to take a [ __ ] or something you
know what I'm saying yeah like a
restaurant club you take a [ __ ] yeah
like hey dude I gotta get in there well
this guy this guy's doing something
that's probably considered technically
illegal in that establishment anyway I'm
Out Swinging he's in trouble yeah and
this is this Australia yeah yeah yeah
yeah and Austria really yeah he's pretty
[ __ ] up let cleaner was love with a
broken nose
might have been doing some coke in there
too by the looks of it
since a year in prison
a year in prison granted immediate
parole though you know yeah
yeah you come out since the cleaner was
left with a broken nose so it was the
guy in the skinny
skinny jeans the cleaner and the white
jeans but he was with a girl too no he
was there why are there so many girls in
this bathroom because it's the women's
bathrooms
of the women's bathroom ex-army
technician Billy report oh so yeah Army
technician the guys I also want to
disable toilet bro yeah that's a lot of
room but hey there's a lot of problems
going on
uh it is frustrating that he's trying to
get his rocks up against like come on
like all right just a second yeah
it is is it like that somebody need to
take a [ __ ] or is he trying to enforce
the rules or is he just being a hater
probably enforce the rules they might be
in there for a hot second doing blow and
whatever they do in Australia Oregon
counties
yeah so this was an interesting thing uh
in eastern Oregon I guess some of these
counties are joining uh voting to join
Idaho which brings up the philosophical
question of do states have the rights to
do this and should we treat you know
counties like no no should they be able
to freely associate with whatever no
you're part of the Republic called the
United States of America yeah we can't
do that you don't get to just you know
can I use that vote next on joining
Idaho well no dude you can't mess up all
the states and [ __ ] just moved Idaho
just like a little you know just like
yeah the line you designed the lines
there's a little a little strange
midterm midterms coming up there's about
to be a red wedding yeah it'll be a red
wedding that's what I heard it's about
to be a red wedding and then here's the
thread here's the song the Democrats
good well those guys so so when you see
that kind of crime [ __ ] crime in the
economy that's what people inflation
inflation economy and crime was third
yeah but inflation economy crime I mean
inflation you you is conflated with
would be in comedy it's economy I mean
they separated with the thing I was
watching but it was inflation number one
economy number two crime number three
and then pronouns are four right
economies
the economy and the Internet by straws
and turtles yeah remember that no it's
it's uh yeah you start
you got DA's who have don't have uh bail
um who don't have any
consequences for when you attack County
staff which is going on in Los Angeles
but you also have like the governor of
New York where they interview him and
she goes we don't have a crime problem
it's like hold on you won't even admit
to the are you out of your mind some
people go it's going to lose I think oh
yeah they haven't been reading forever
and you can't even admit there's a crime
problem if you if you don't think it's
fine that means you're not going to put
resources into it you know you do
anything to fix also means you don't
live in the real [ __ ] correct but
also if she's just like yeah we have a
problem trying to figure it out I think
people will be more willing to side with
it but you just want to be an idiot
about it all right oh Kevin wait guys
hold on
Whoopi Goldberg is leaving Twitter guys
I just announced uh what the [ __ ] what
do I want to do opinions I heard points
are so good I mean so good Whoopi
Goldberg what am I going to do without
your [ __ ] point of view on everything
so this place is all the libs leaving so
this place is a mess I'm taking my bomb
massive yeah we can't spread
misinformation don't take your ball and
go home I don't know what we're gonna do
without you I know I wonder where
they're gonna I guess there's double
down on Instagram I listen to her on The
View I'd rather [ __ ] have somebody
drill my teeth with no no I can't
believe you listen to him I don't know
what the [ __ ] you're saying I just
sometimes I hate watch that [ __ ] I get
it Jacko they're so dumb I'm just like
okay what do you got Jen
um was it meteor one yucky
there you go Mark yeah so this dude
here's a big sound runs out and his
house is like immediately engulfed in
flamed so you know unless somebody's
throwing a bomb at his house or
something like that imagine the odds of
that your house I heard a big bang I
started to smell smoke I went under my
porch of completely engulfed in flames
they said it was a new year
oh this video will be getting lit up
pretty wild yeah how the [ __ ] they catch
video on this Sam's home it happens it's
the meteor camera Oh north of Sacramento
take a look at that boom since he was at
home when he heard a big bang and
started to smell smoke then discovered
his porch was on fire as firefighters
worked put it out people started showing
up to his house because they said they
saw a flash in the sky so that wasn't me
one individual tell me about it first by
the end of it okay
quickly but there's more video I wanted
you guys to see the front porch oh
hopefully they play that yeah right
after this maybe two three lost his
teeth too I guess I might be buying a
lottery ticket today
to figure out exactly what started that
different videos there was some video
from his front porch whereas like the
the porch Cam that actually showed it
like engulfing in Flames damn I don't
know where it is now but um
anyway you get the idea it's pretty
crazy do you know the Powerball in
California is 1.2 billion dollars
so it's the highest ever been 1.2
billion dollars Jesus Christ
I want that money
I'm going to play
last one you can take your lump sum up
front I was listening they'll give you
989 million dollars up front okay
so here we have more if you get over the
years
what else you got mine that uh there's a
newborn baby in India that doctors
noticed she had an extended belly and
they ended up taking out eight embryos
from her stomach so I guess it's a super
rare condition where you essentially
like engulf your twin you know in the
womb and uh not just once but eight of
these
so they're all dead yeah they're like
inside her body first I'm like wait was
she impregnated or something is that
possible then a baby girl
that's so crazy you see the picture and
they say it's one out of they're like
this happens in one out of every 500 000
bursts but I'm like you can't even be
that High babies that's pretty graphic
that is oh she's a little cute bunny
yeah hold the infant had the embryos yes
I wonder when you tell her huh you're
like hey she'll be okay yeah hopefully
she's okay Jesus Christ let's send this
stuff from fetus
um my kid's eight nine months old ten
months old doesn't have that much hair
not even close to that much hair
yeah but early on
and it's a little red it's going to be a
situation
that poor bunny that's terrible man is
that it that's it
well
um well you just land on that um Houston
this Thursday Friday Saturday Houston
Improv is this Thursday Friday Saturday
the parents at Spec's downtown from noon
to two o'clock come try that
award-winning thick nectar I'll be there
the thick boy Squad will be there we'll
have some merch there for you if you
finally want to get your hands on a
bottle we're gonna have all the cases
all the bottles of tiger thick that
specs this Saturday noon to two but then
uh the club will also be loaded up as
well so now's your time to try it
Houston it's my biggest market so all
shows at the Houston Improv Thursday
Friday Saturday will have tiger think
available to taste on taste on I'll be
there as well sipping on stage as usual
get your tickets then next week
Milwaukee's just Friday Saturday
Milwaukee improv Friday Saturday
definitely going on my own uh Jeffrey
Dahmer tour there come get some
Milwaukee next Friday Saturday
uh then two dates left in rest of the
year December coming in hot Providence
Rhode Island's almost sold out never
been there looking forward to it
Providence December 1st through the 3rd
I don't know where that's at on the
calendar or on the map and then
Washington DC DC Improv December 15th
through 17th DC Improv get your tickets
at thickboy.com get your tiger thick
sent to your house thick boy.com all
right listen up Charlotte North Carolina
comedy show November 10 11 12. Addison
Texas Addison Improv November 17 18 19
Naples Florida off the hook December one
two three and four you got some good
ones yeah I do I'm not going to talk
about West Nyack I may have to cancel
that I'm sorry everybody uh I have to
find out the fight campaign we'll find
out today yeah that's right there we go
that's it all right kids love you this
is the fine kid we're out